I think it's going pretty well.
It's quite a lot of fun to have a little baby round together.
I mean,
I think like most man,
I'm somewhat nonplus let's say by infants.
Um,
it's easier for me to deal with kids after they're about,
once they get mobile.
I once I can sort of throw them around a bit more than I know what to do with
them once I can play with them.
But,
um,
it's really fun to watch my daughter be a mother.
She's really good at it and it's good to have another young thing in the family
and you know,
cause babies are very,
they're kind of like fire you,
you can't help but watch them and
it's great.
It's great.
And she seems healthy and um,
you know what?
She's cute as can be.
Of course babies are sneaky that way,
but it's working.
So yeah,
I think it's really going well.